not that good yeah like as a person so
maybe that was why she was with him
and you know one last
goodbye ah man you can't pick and choose
you can't in it she's a sacrifice if
she's asking for it in the last nine
months of life so what have i got to do
with you you know why i got a deal with
you that it is but then you wouldn't you
wouldn't next whole package and then at
the last nine months she wants to die
but then can i play devil's advocate
what if we can just say like this is
just physical right i know we're going
to talk about like intimacy and
emotional for men it's just physical if
you let me if you're letting me before
these nine months you do me do my thing
you got nine months ago and then
but you're not going to let me do my
thing so it's like
it's different in it for men for men
it's just physical but i where men can
just soldier on though
well what
do you why are you shaking your head
for men it's it's like not emotional
it's just physical
women can be exactly the same i have
been in that person i have been that
person where i have gone and done what i
felt like i needed to do and had no
emotional connection i just wanted to
have that one experience or
wouldn't you say by and large though
women are attached more emotion to sex
because we release a hormone that men
don't during sex yeah so there's like a
bonding hormone and it's the more
partners you sleep with the less you
release that hormone so a lot of times
like when girls say that it's like
they they had a lot of partners so they
don't release the hormone as much
anymore yeah that's probably where i'm
at
wow oh you didn't know that that makes
so much sense
yeah because particularly like very
i don't like have loads of sexual
partners so i'm really careful because i
know i can get emotionally attached so i
prefer to do it in a relationship or get
pissed off if i'm
in a situation it's happening it's not
worked out so that makes so much sense i
didn't know that well and that's why
like um
a lot of times they say a girl can't
fall in love unless she's had the best
sex of her life because it's like that's
how girls bond is like
when they that makes sense yeah when
they orgasm yeah so it's like
it's different but men on the other hand
they can have sex with a hole in the
wall and they'll be fine
but no no i feel like a lot of men
though i mean exactly
majority of men like i've asked this
question like have you ever slept with a
girl that you wouldn't be seen in public
with 100 all men have done that yeah and
so ninety nine percent of men have done
that but that's kind of the problem with
the sexual marketplace because
essentially like the small percentage of
men are sleeping with all the girls and
so then like girls think they're on that
level but they're not yeah because like
your level is what you can get to take
you out in public basically okay yeah
that's a fact
there's a lot of girls men wouldn't be
seen with that they've [ __ ] oh can i
say that wait no you can you can say
that's it there's a lot of girls that
men wouldn't be seen within public that
they've had sexual relations with
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's similar to
when you have a date you have a blind
date and he turns up and you're like oh
dear
i can't go anywhere that i was planning
on going and now i need to hide yeah so
it's it works both ways but maybe the
sex doesn't happen that's a bit
different
and you'll get the food and you're going
to [ __ ] off and not see that guy yeah
that guy's suffering
this whole situation is kind of
unfortunate
because i think i've i've actually been
that person
so there was like um i did this like
american girl she was cali like light
blue hair
really into like every sexual thing you
could imagine was this like left crazy
liberals you can identify us as like a
man
but was this heterosexual but also he's
a lesbian she had all the tags
and we were messing around and one of
her her last guy was like
when we hung out she really liked this
guy like she really cherished the
friendship and she tells me that yeah we
spent the night together and it was
trash like like the d was trash
but like the love between them like she
really cherishes this guy um so
yeah and i was there like i mean you
know
the provider
you're fine
it's unfortunate i just think i find it
really bizarre that a woman or a man can
have sex with someone that they're
i don't know not attracted to like that
or
they don't feel something for
i find that really bizarre well it's
it's because it's got to have con
there's got to be a connection if i've
got no connection with you
there's no way it's going to work
it's just right but we're thinking from
a woman's point of view so from from
like the typical woman's point of view
like we're thinking how on earth could
you have sex with someone like guys will
have sex with girls they hate yeah yeah
you know what it is though but guys yeah
i can't speak for every guy but it's
that
it's that post you know i don't know
what was yeah but exactly clarity
listen i'm not gonna lie like oh [ __ ]
i've spoke to like the man them and and
i've asked them
like questions like that like have you
ever and then a lot of guys do is after
the mission complete yeah
they're like oh i should have aborted
this mission beforehand but you don't
see that reality until
like only a very disciplined and aware
man and
very like yeah it's not the i'll feel
that majority can definitely sleep with
someone and not feel nothing for them
you know i ain't here for a relationship
is that
yeah i have a lot of mates that say
oh yeah i slept with this girl but i
don't faint here i don't i don't i don't
like her and i'm like what
why why did he let me there in the first
place
like there is no way why'd she sleep
with him you know because most girls you
kind of know what a guy's after like a
lot of times girls we pretend we don't
know we kind of like act like because we
want the attention from the guy but we
know we know which guys actually like us
and which ones are just oh yeah we just
pretending we sometimes say no i don't i
don't know then yeah but yeah as a woman
you you already know you already know if
it's gonna be a prick or not yeah
straight away yeah
but but it's crazy though because a lot
of times the same girls will cry later
and say men are trash but how can you
say men are trash when you picked them
yeah yeah yourself
people aren't clear
people aren't fully honest
right so
someone will tell you everything you
want to hear
in order to get what they want 100 right
and then when they get what they want
they might think oh you know what i like
that i want that again
i'm going to keep lying
they're going to get that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing
but it's all based on a lie i've i've
found more that get what girls will do
is the guy will be broad
and say oh i'm i'm looking you know he
might not say specifically what he's
looking for but if you say are you
looking for a relationship
specifically like they usually tell you
the truth yeah yeah yes or no
like
no they might say no i'm not cool no and
i don't think they do
i think there's a good twenty percent of
people that lie
the right guys the right guys the
scumbag will not i don't want to say
that about a guy that doesn't get a lot
of girls will do i don't think it's just
that dog or a guy that's not confident
in himself we'll tell you what you want
to hear but a guy that knows what he
wants to exactly
you know it is i feel like guys like
because it's so easy a guy that knows
what he wants will just tell you
like
the kind of guy i am if i wasn't with my
girl knows this as well
i don't beat around the bush if i'm
trying to [ __ ] a girl i'll just let you
know straight up listen i'm trying to
hit what are you saying and if it's not
that and to get out it's not just a
random girl either it's a girl that i
would have interacted with before
obviously you don't